– Lisa? Du, es tut uns leid.
Wir wollten dich vorhin nicht stören.
– Nein, es ist nur ... mein Arbeitsplan
macht mich total verrückt.
Ich weiß echt nicht, wie ich das
alles schaffen soll.
– Wolltest du nicht ’n paar Sprachkurse
absagen? Oder die Privatstunden?
Ist doch unglaublich stressig, wenn du
zu jedem Einzelnen hinmusst.
– Das ist kein Stress für mich. Außerdem:
Mit wem sollen sie denn sonst lernen?
– In ’ner Gruppe? Oder zu zweit?
Du könntest dich auch mit ihnen in der
Bibliothek treffen … oder ins Café gehen.
– Ich weiß, ich muss
irgendwas reduzieren. Aber ich …
ich will niemanden im Stich lassen.
– Lisa …
– Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Ich denk drüber nach.
Aber jetzt muss ich erst mal neues Material
für die nächste Förderstunde
zusammensuchen.
– Was ist das Thema?
– Es geht um Berufe.
So, wo sind jetzt meine Notizen?
Die haben doch eben noch hier gelegen.
Oder hab ich die in der Küche
liegen lassen?
– Okay. Hör auf zu suchen.
Ich hab ’ne Idee!